movies are like games of Jenga if just
one piece is out of place the entire
thing collapses no matter how wellb
built the rest of it is even movies that
otherwise were great have been ruined by
a bad decision here's a look at movies
that were destroyed by just one scene
The Dark Knight Rises was full of little
head scratching moments such as if the
villain's plan is to blow up Gotham
after holding it hostage why does it
wait all those months to do it most of
these you can just let slide but the
reveal of Joseph Gordon lit's real
identity that's that's just too much you
know Robin of course in the comics
Robin's real name is dick or Jason or
Tim or Daman or even Stephanie but
apparently any of those names would have
been too subtle for movie audiences so
they hit you over the head with it
instead it's like revealing this dude's
name is John Aquaman or something at the
climax of Christopher Nolan's sci-fi
epic Interstellar Matthew mcc's pilot
character falls into a black hole and
lands inside a far-flung future device
that lets him send cryptic messages to
his daughter in the past or in other
words he has to use some hippie dippy
Morse code machine to save the future
using That's right The Power of Love no
no no no no no no
no no no really love that's the secret
to unlocking the mysteries of the
SpaceTime Continuum Great Scott there
was a minute there where it looked like
Ridley Scott's Prometheus was going to
be one of the coolest movies ever made
but what it turned out to be was a slow
exercise in cluelessness plenty of fans
either love or hate it but it's hard to
argue about that one sequence where the
characters have to avoid being crushed
by a rolling spaceship it looks tense
exciting thrilling even right up until
you ask yourself why didn't they just
move to the side instead of trying to
outrun it in fact the main character
lives by simply rolling 3 feet now if
she had only told her buddy to do the
same thing maybe we wouldn't have left
the theater feeling profoundly
stupider throughout the majority of 12
Years a Slave the story of Solomon
Northrup a free man who is kidnapped and
forced into slavery is artfully told
through brutal visuals and compelling
performances then Brad Pit shows up and
he speaks using whatever accent this was
supposed to be with his Brad Pit acting
and his Brad Pit face my freedom is
everything the fact that I can walk out
of here tomorrow brings me great
pleasure uh start walking Brad that
would give us great
pleasure Let the Right One In is a rare
kind of horror movie A Haunting
character study with few loud moments
are overt scares it is simply put an
excellent creepy flick but it does have
one massive unintentional Belly Laugh
moment that kind of ruins
[Music]
it here's a free tip to any future
horror movie directors if you want to
keep your audience terrified and on the
edge of their seats just skip the evil
attack kittens kittens can't really pull
off the evil thing you know they're just
too damn cute I'm going to kill you
in 1997 fans were excited at the chance
to see the remastered Star Wars Trilogy
on the big screen and then this happened
I bet you
have in an instant people realized
George Lucas hadn't improve the series
with special editions it ruined it the
collective scream of distraught fans is
still reverberating around the Universe
I felt a great disturbance in the force
as if millions of voices suddenly cried
out in Terror and was suddenly silenced
well maybe not exactly
silenced now you can almost understand
the thought process behind having greo
shoot first but for every revision Lucas
has explained there are at least three
others made to the trilogy that are just
random and bizarre and none of them are
more random or more bizarre than the
insanely stupid Jedi Rocks dance number
in the middle of Return of the Jedi
prepare yourselves I have a very bad
feeling about
[Music]
this
no
no I don't really have a lot of awards
to be very honest with you to say that
Peter Parker's dance scene ruined
Spider-Man 3 is a bit of an exaggeration
since there's so much more wrong with
the film The misfired Sandman CGI the
underwhelming Venom and James Franco's
pipe eting performance all contributed
to the Flop that was Spider-Man 3 but
all that pales in comparison to Peter
Parker dancing at the Jazz Club Toby
McGuire's awkward hip thrusting and
finger snapping as he gazes through his
messy Banks play more like a bad SNL
sketch than anything that ever should
have made it into a superhero movie now
take on
this how many people choked him at
popcorn when he actually said that
because seriously that's awful the scene
where neo fights a crap load of agent
Smiths was supposed to be one of the
major action set pieces but the Matrix
Reloaded but the second the fighting
begins both Neo and agent Smith get
replaced with CGI so terrible it makes
the Sims look like virtual reality the
scene was meant to follow up the
groundbreaking bullet time effects of
the first movie instead the botched
effects proed to audiences that neither
Matrix sequel would even come close to
touching the original John mlan has done
a lot of wildly unrealistic things in
his accidental encounters with
terrorists but none have even come close
to single-handedly fighting and beating
an actual fighter jet Live Free or Die C
is far from the best movie in the series
but it was still pretty good even after
being watered down from an R rating to a
PG-13 rating that is until the
filmmakers just said f it and went to
Crazy Town in this scene there's the
laughable ease with which a hacker takes
command of the Marine jet to the rud
Goldberg es way the highway perfectly
falls apart to let mlan escape the
entire scene should have just stayed in
the imagination of the six-year-old who
probably thought it up also how is mlan
able to drive a semi you know what never
mind that's actually the least
ridiculous thing here with the help of a
parachute a piece of a plane and video
effects that would embarrass a high
school AV club James Bond surfs on what
appears to be a 100 foot wave of Arctic
water in Die Another Day this scene has
been cited as the death nail for Pierce
broen's Bond it took four years and the
casting of Daniel Craig for the series
to redeem itself from that time a James
Bond movie looked like it was ripped on
the PlayStation 2 video game cut scene
but we'll never forget your bond died
that day Pierce make no mistake of the
many things that catch blame for ruining
the Star Wars prequels jarar murans
almost every line of dialogue George
Lucas wrote for Padme and Anakin there
is one moment that makes almost every
fan cringe no matter how dedicated we're
talking about Anakin Skywalker's charred
transformation into Darth Vader
literally the jumping off of the entire
Star Wars saga In This Moment Vader
learned he's lost his wife and unborn
children and had been transformed into
like a space RoboCop what does he do he
does this
no it felt silly when it should have
been tear jerking and a captain
performance by Hayden Christensen that
was so unlikable that he went from that
guy poised to be this generation's
Harrison Ford to the guy who was in that
bank heist movie with Chris Brown and
tii if you ever found yourself being
attacked by a velociraptor you'd
probably wet your pants and run away
screaming with that in mind it's
impossible not to lose total faith in
Jurassic part The Lost World when Kelly
Malcolm the spunky daughter of Dr Ian
Malcolm stands her ground against one of
the lethal dinosaurs by putting her
gymnastic training to the test watching
a kid hold her own against one of the
franchises nastiest villains is
undeniable cool but the way she does it
falling off and kicking the creature
through a window is entirely
unbelievable sure this is a movie about
dinosaurs being brought back to life but
dof fighting gymnastics skills are just
a bridge too far the Lord of the Rings
trilogy leisurely pace is part of its
charm when you watch one of these movies
you know you're setting in for a truly
epic adventure but even by those
standards the concluding chapter the
return to the King goes on for what
seems like forever especially in the
Final Act where it seems to have like
four or five endings it's always hard to
say say goodbye to a great cinematic
Saga so we can't begrudge director Peter
Jackson for his fond froto farewell
except for the scene where the hobbits
Frolic on top of a bed in Gauzy light
and slow motion after spending all those
hours with froto Sam wise and the rest
of the gang we want to be laughing with
them not at them most people have never
gone to a Transformers movie expecting a
sensible plot or characters worth caring
that much about we line up for these
things for awesome special effects and
director Michael B is more than happy to
deliver unfortunately ba isn't always
content to just blow stuff up
sometimes he wants to be funny too and
that's what led to the introduction of
skids and mud flap in Revenge of the
Fallen forget about robots and disguise
these two are racist caricatures out in
the open trading on every offensive
stereotype in the book b later tried to
throw the voice actors under the bus by
blaming the character's demeanor on
faulty line readings but no one bought
it skids and mug laap were even cut from
the next movie in the franchise Dark of
the Moon by the time Indiana Jones and
the kingdom of the Crystal Skull arrived
in 2008 we've been waiting for a new
indie adventure for nearly 20 years
almost nothing could have killed our
Buzz for getting to spend another 2
hours with our favorite archaeologist in
the end while it's no one's favorite
Indiana Jones movie most folks were
willing to forgive most of its flaws
except the infamous nuking the fridge
sequence even in a movie that asks us to
suspend our disbelief far enough to
accept Indie making contact with aliens
this awful action setpiece which finds
Indie miraculously surviving a nuclear
test Blast by using a leadline
refrigerator shelter is laughable and
ranks is one of the few true missteps in
a beloved branch
the first four Superman movies weren't
all great films by any means but they
had a certain sweetness about them that
reflected the character's optimism in
the comics all that changed when Zack
Snider took the range for 2013's Man of
Steel although darker overtones were
probably to be expected in the post-
Dark Knight world it was still difficult
for many longtime fans to accept the
rampant casual destruction Superman
helped Unleashed during his battle with
Zod in the Final Act even harder to
accept was his decision to end the fight
by snapping zod's neck Snider has
defended his decision repeatedly but
that Point Remains the focus of intense
debate for some fans it undermines the
entire concept of the character and when
they saw it go down in the theater they
had one unavoidable
[Music]
reaction